- [Narrator] This is the
Black Beauty Stick insect.
A rare bug found only
in a tiny 12 acre area,
high in the remote
mountains of Northern Peru.
(upbeat music)
Discovered in 2005,
the Black Beauty Stick Insect
has a velvet black body
covered in small bristles.
The only other colors
on its body are its
piercing golden yellow eyes
and it's bright red wings.
Not much is known about this species,
but scientists have observed
it to be most active at night,
when its deep black coloration,
keeps it hidden from predators.
In addition to its powerful
nighttime camouflage,
the Black Beauty Stick Insect is armed
with a gland at the rear of its head,
and when threatened,
can spray a coercive,
strong smelling substance
at its attacker.
Because their natural habitat is so small,
the Black Beauty Stick Insect’s
survival is precarious.
And because of its striking features,
they have become a popular
insect in the pet trade.
Luckily, due to successful
captive breeding efforts,
this particular threat
may be on the decline.
This is the Black Beauty Stick Insect.
(upbeat music)
(tinkly music)